Here's why.
I want to talk to you about the brain
a little bit because if you make the
radical case,
let's say that these are actually the
categories of reality and we're going to
say,
well reality is what selects
for this for the sake of,
for this,
for the sake of argument.
Then the then are our
neurological structures and
our physical structure should
be adapted to that reality.
It's it's,
it's a,
it's a necessary conclusion from that.
So then the question is,
well are they,
and as far as I can tell,
the answer to that is yes,
and so we'll,
we'll go through the,
the neuropsychological
evidence quite rapidly.
The first bit of evidence is
that you have two hemispheres.
Why one deals with the unknown and the
other deals with the known that sale
Conan Goldberg.
And that's,
that's hypothesized completely
independently of any of this underlying
mythological substructure,
which is really important thing to note
because if you're trying to determine
whether or not something is true,
valid,
if the constructs upon which you base
your thinking are valid and true,
there's rules for doing that.
And one of the rules is you have to
be able to detect the existence of the
categories using multiple methods of,
of uh,
of,
of what,
using multiple methods.
It's the multi-method multitrack matrix.
Technically speaking,
it was established as a technique by
two psychologists named crone back C,
R,
O n,
B,
a,
c h and meal M,
e e h l,
Paul Meehl back in the
1950s when psychologists,
we're trying to figure out how do you
determine if something actually has an
existence like anger or anxiety
as something that you could study
scientifically.
And the answer is,
well you have to be able to measure it
multiple ways and all those measurements
have to read the same way.
And then the question is,
well,
what do you mean by multiple ways?
Cause his sight and vision and his sight
and hearing different while somewhat
and somewhat the same,
but you know,
you do,
you make them as different
as you can manage,
let's say.
And our sensory systems
are quite different smell,
molecular signature sound is auditory are,
you know,
auditory pressure.
You need a gas around you or some
liquid in order for that to occur.
Site uses light.
You know,
we're,
we're using different inputs that
converge and allow us to say,
well,
if we get convergent information
across these multiple measurements,
then we'll assume that the
thing we're perceiving as real,
we even extend that in science because
we say if you take your multiple
measurement system and
you take your multiple,
multiple measurement system and then
you compare them will only allow what's
constant across both those
comparisons to be real.
And so that's the multi-method multi
trade matrix process essentially.
And my sense is that,
so I,
I think that the pattern
that I'm describing to you,
it's manifested itself evolutionarily.
It manifest itself at the neural,
in the learner logical space
and it manifest itself in
the conceptual space and
probability of all three of those things
happening at the same time without
there being something valid.
There is lessons with each
level of interpretation you
manage to stack on top of
one another.
So that's the,
that's the method.
Well,
so,
well let's think about the
brain a little bit and I'll,
I'll tell you a little bit
about how the brain works and,
and you know,
a lot of this stuff I'm telling
you right now is quite old.
Actually.
Most of it was worked out in the 19,
in the 1980s but it's been remarkably
stable as far as I can tell.
In some sense we're filling in the
details and not in every sense,
but in some sense we're
filling in the details.
Okay.
So you take,
this is from Alexander
Luria who was the greatest,
perhaps the greatest
neuropsychologist who ever lived.
He was a Russian,
uh,
more work,
mostly after the Second World War,
mostly on people who had brain damage.
And he was interested in
trying to outline the,
the,
the overarching picture of brain function.
And so he did that partly
by looking at its function,
but also partly by
looking at its structure,
trying to get both of those
things working simultaneously.
And so we'll go through a brief
picture of how the brain works.
And so one of the ways of,
so you can,
you can look at the brain from front to
back and you can divided roughly into
two sections and one section has to
do with sensory processing and that's
roughly the back half and one
section has to do with motor output.
Now those things aren't,
has clearly differentiated as
you might think because you,
there's very little sensation
without motor output.
Maybe the,
the pot,
the closest to an exception is smell,
I would say.
But you at least have to breathe in,
you know,
and when an animal is actively
searching out a scent trail,
it's breathing in.
So it's,
it's using its motor output constantly
to modify the sensory stream.
It's really difficult
to dissociate the two.
And when you're looking at something,
you know,
it kind of feels to you like you're
a passive recipient of sense data,
but you're no such thing.
Your eyes are,
are moving back and forth in
multiple ways all the time,
including the ways that you
can control voluntarily.
So there's multiple involuntary systems
that are moving your eyes in multiple
ways.
And really what you're
doing is feeling the,
the array of,
of electromagnetic,
of the electromagnetic
spectrum with your eyes.
You're feeling it and you're actively
exploring if you're not a passive
recipient at all.
So even in sensation,
you can't purely pull sensation
out for motor processing and say,
I'm getting untrammeled unbiased census
data because you can't look at something
without focusing and you can't focus
without wanting to look at something.
You know,
you can't just lie there with you while
you could with your eyes have cross.
But you know,
that's sort of like,
imagine you dropped a video recorder from
an airplane and it just spun around in
an unfocused manner.
Well that's the world sampled randomly.
You know,
why do you,
what are you gonna do with that?
Nothing.
And you know,
your,
you're concentrating on the,
on the,
on the auditory stream constantly
and segregating out some things and
suppressing others.
Like if you listen in the classroom,
you can hear
probably four or five different types
of mechanical noise going on at the same
time.
Most of the time in the
classroom that's silent.
You don't hear it like you don't hear
your fridge except when it turns on or
off.
Right is zero that out and so you're
very selective in your perception,
so you can't really technically separate
out motor output from sensory input and
that's really useful to know because
it destroys the idea that you're just a
path.
You know that there's that
world of sensation out there
that's imprinting itself
on you and that's how
you get your information,
which is really the,
that's the fundamental presupposition of
the empiricists of the raw empiricists.
There's a world of sense data out there.
You sample it randomly and
that's what informs you.
It's like,
yes,
except that you're always an active
harvest or of the information so you can't
get rid of the interpretive
structure a priority.
That was a manual count by the way,
who first established out in
his critique of pure reason.
You can't get away from the fact that
you're actively harvesting the data so you
can say,
well,
where does human structure come from?
The sense data that's sort
of the blank slate idea.
It's like no wrong because a blank
slate cannot process information.
You're actively engaged
right at the beginning.
So that's another example of
the knower and the unknown.
You know,
working in a cyclical manner because you
interact with something you divided up
into you,
you and the world roughly speaking and
I mean you really make it that way cause
you build yourself out of the information
and then of course that makes you a
more differentiated processor
with a broader range of skills.
Then you interact with the unknown.
Again,
you gather more information at,
differentiates the world.
It makes you a more
differentiated harvester.
And then so it's just continually
cycling and that consciousness,
the logos,
the knower is that thing that's doing
that harvesting and you can never say it's
not there.
Now what happens is that it's in
it's nascent form to begin with,
low resolution,
nascent form,
low resolution knower,
low resolution category system,
low resolution world.
But that's enough to kickstart it
and to start a differentiating.
And that happens as you
develop as an individual
because you start out as
a single celled organism,
for all intents and purposes,
a very low resolution thing in
a very low resolution world.
And that differentiates
itself across time.
But exactly the same thing
happened over evolutionary time.
So,
so there isn't a time when those
three elements aren't there.
For all intents and purposes,
they're always there.
They're permanent.